bonsoir madame la marche en sport ça
tombe bien là vous avez mené une enquête
sur la satisfaction des gens vers les
fournisseurs de télécommunications ça
bave paraître mardi dans un dossier
spécial
si on en parle aujourd'hui c'est parce
que le crtc voir révisé à la baisse son
appel des tarifs de gros ans qui est
payé par les petits joueurs pour avoir
accès finalement au réseau des grands
joueurs c'est bon en perspective pour
les gens ça pour les prix qu'on paie
mais on l'espère si les petits joueurs
paient moins cher pour avoir accès aux
infrastructures
on espère que ça va transparaître dans
la facture que paient les consommateurs
et puis qu'on va tous pouvoir finalement
économiser sur nos forfaits internet et
nous un forfait s'il a alors suscité un
espoir moi je t'ai vu bull oui
présentement you rien d'annoncé c'est
sûr qu'on va suivre ça dans les
prochains jours sur notre site web on a
aussi un comparateur gratuit de forfaits
cellulaires et de forfaits internet qui
est vraiment mis à jour quotidiennement
donc on va suivre ça et puis on va on
espère le voir apparaître des baisses
dans les prochains jours pour tous les
joueurs les petits comme les grands mais
c'est sûr que là présentement sur les
petits joueurs qui vont bénéficier de
baisses ou de baisses de coûts de
de production en fait oui par contre un
des conseils qu'on donne c'est vraiment
toujours de négocier et plus la
meilleure façon négocié c'est un savoir
ce que les autres offres
et puis à ce moment là on est capable
vers vers notre retard actuel puis dire
voici ce que j'ai vu ailleurs êtes vous
capable de m'offrir donc à partir du
moment où il ya des gens qui commencent
à bouger des joueurs qui commencent à
bouger mais tout le monde peut en
profiter en essayant de faire négocier
dans les sphères négocié sont portés à
la baisse voir venir la négociation et à
ce qu'on peut faire parce que je l'homme
qu'on pose la question suivante les
joueurs avec lesquels on est encore un
peu familier ebook suffisent par exemple
jusqu'à quel point on peut leur faire
confiance
notre sondage le score qui va vraiment
ressortir notre sondage c'est que les
petits joueurs sans faire très bien ils
obtiennent des hauts taux de
satisfaction pour le service à la
clientèle pour la qualité des connexions
et aussi pour les prix des biens
meilleurs toute satisfaction que
beaucoup de grands joueurs de
l'industrie
parce que pour le service à la clientèle
notamment dans certains camps il ya
personnes clés qui ont et qu'on peut
appeler la ccl france en particulier un
modèle d'affaires un peu particulier où
les prix sont très bas mais en
contrepartie on ne peut pas accès à un
service à la clientèle autres qu'en
ligne donc ça veut dire que des forums
des clavardages peut-être courriel c'est
sûr que free c'est assez nouveau il ya
eu des ratés des pépins techniques lors
de la mise en place du service
je pense qu'on peut attendre un petit
peu pour voir le vrai mais qu'est ce qui
arrive pour tirer des grandes
conclusions vagues à montréal c'est près
de 20 % des gens qui leur font confiance
à ce statut selon les dernières données
maintenant vous l'avez dit on peut
négocier la bonne vieille négociations
en parlant des prix qu'on vous offre
ailleurs on peut peut-être obtenir mieux
avec que ceux avec qui on fait affaire
mais allons-y étape par étape laquelle
que sont les paramètres qu'on doit
surveiller quand on doit négocier bon
pour négocier mais c'est vraiment de
faire le tour de ski sur le marché pour
avoir vraiment toutes les informations
en main pour pouvoir bien négocier c'est
certain au sibac si on regarde les
données notre sondage on voit que les
gens ont économisé quand même beaucoup
en négoce
ça peut aller jusqu'à 20 en moyenne
jusqu'à 27 dollars mais il ya des gens
qui nous ont parlé de 50 dollars
d'économie par mois
donc si on rapporte que fait plusieurs
centaines de dollars d'économies par
année ça vaut vraiment la peine de
tenter le jeu ça fonctionne pas toujours
mais opère vous aurez perdu le bon 15
minutes 20 minutes dans votre journée
puis au mieux mais vous allez pouvoir
économiser beaucoup entre téléphonie et
internet ainsi qu'une différence une
différence d'approché cela convienne
moment justement de gérer tout ça d'être
dans cette quête du prix un peu m
importe ici pas les mêmes choses qu'il
faut comparer si vous êtes à la
recherche d'un forfait cellulaire
pourront bien sûr d'avoir la première
chose à savoir c'est est-ce que vous
gardez votre téléphone où vous avez
besoin d'un nouveau téléphone
et puis si vous avez besoin d'un nouveau
téléphone la possibilité de l'acheter
plein prix ou de le prendre avec un
forfait
il ya quelques années c'était souvent
plus intéressant d'acheter le téléphone
plein prix maintenant soit il écrit son
meilleur lorsqu'on prend un forfait un
contrat qui est généralement sur 2 ha
pour bien comparer nous ce qu'on
conseille c'est de comparer le prix sur
200 justement parce que des fois on va
voir le téléphone un peu plus cher mais
un forfait un peu moins cher et vice et
versa donc ça vaut la peine de faire le
calcul bon au bout de deux ans combien
ça va en avoir pour des pneus on peut
comparer le sur la même base ou est ce
qui reste imprévisible c'est la réaction
des gros joueurs dans tout ça oui
finalement si beaucoup un phénomène
urbain les quand on parle de physio et
les autres petits joueurs c'est surtout
dans les grands centres urbains que ça
se passe en région sur une autre réalité
tout à fait puis on l'a vu aussi dans
notre sondage laouli l'insatisfaction
est la plus palpable c'est souvent
région déjà bon d'abord des fois il ya
seulement un fournisseur le donc à ce
moment là non seulement c'est impossible
de négocier mais souvent le service à la
clientèle laisse à désirer aussi la
qualité de la connexion
donc lorsqu'on et par région c'est
beaucoup beaucoup plus compliqué de
d'avoir un forfait un bon forfait à bon
prix très bien merci beaucoup
même la marge de rappel mardi prochain
dans protégez-vous ce sera à lire merci
au revoir